[Musique]
c'est notre rêve d'enfants qui nous
donne la force d'avancer
moi j'ai toujours aimé la mer je vous
propose une petite expérience
nous allons fermer les yeux quelques
secondes et jalouse à nous asseoir face
à l'océan
je suis sur le pont d'un bateau d'un
marin que j'aimais beaucoup jean maurel
j'ai démarché de manivelle de winch et
je rêve déjà de grands espaces je viens
de faire 30 fois le tour du bateau en
sautant sur un trampoline et j'en
redemande encore à l'époque mon grand
père me disait l'iliade et l'odyssée
j'apprenais des poèmes de prévert en
chantant j'ai toujours aimé la mer j'ai
fait un rêve un soir que je partirai au
large en solitaire
ce rêve ne m'a jamais quitté à l'école
j'ai passé plus de temps à regarder les
nuages et le vent dans les arbres qu'à
écouter mes professeurs
je n'arrivais pas à rester plus de cinq
minutes sur une chaise et je rêvais de
grimper dans les arbres
malheureusement la cour était en béton
n'ai jamais vraiment compris pourquoi
les cours étaient en béton j'aurais
préféré pouvoir jouer pieds nus et
courir après un ballon
j'ai eu cette chance incroyable de
pouvoir faire sport-études voile en 6e j
ai appris le vivre ensemble
on partait en groupe de plusieurs
personnes pendant plusieurs jours
pendant plusieurs semaines on partait en
mer où on partait en voyage et on y
apprenait à vivre ensemble avec l'autre
on y apprenait le partage et cette
exigence du haut niveau et de
dépassement de soi mais pour continuer
mon rêve j'ai dû convaincre les indécis
notamment mon père grand marin qui me
disait arthur arrêtent de rêver
ils voulaient me protéger bien sûr mais
je n'ai pas écouté
pour continuer cette aventure j'ai dû
aussi me trouver des partenaires
financiers
c'est un grand défi aussi j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps à démarcher des
entreprises en 2010 je réussis à faire
la solitaire du figaro quelques
partenaires et entreprises me
soutiennent et je suis benjamin de la
course
je finis une place honorable jeu j'ai
apprend plein de métiers en accéléré du
métier de communicant le métier pour
construire des bateaux dessinés dévoile
vie je mets la nedo menée dans le moteur
aussi pour apprendre à réparer
et voilà que viennent des événements qui
bouleversent une vie j'ai failli perdre
usage de mon bras droit
nous sommes en mer à palma en espagne et
le vent est fort a fallu nous sommes sur
un bateau de 20 mètres en équipage cette
fois-ci tout à coup une pièce
accastillage lâche et la cox avait
enroulé la voile sans tout autour de mon
bras je monte en l'air a propulsé comme
une brindille et part d'instinct je me
raccroche à l'été du bateau je regrette
le long de l'été et je tombe de tout mon
poids sur le pont du bateau je perds
quelques secondes connaissances et en me
réveillant j'ai une brad qui prend à
côté de moi
inerte une douleur atroce commence à
grandir et quelques heures passent avant
de rentrer au port là une magnifique
infirmières aux yeux bleu turquoise me
donne une bonne dose de morphine vous
dire que ça faisait du bien
s'ensuit une longue période de
convalescence où je passe beaucoup de
temps sans trop dur éducation et entre
deux séances dans ce centre je passe
aussi énormément de temps avec une kiné
formidable julie qui dépasse largement
mon seuil de douleur
en fait le projet c'est de décoller tous
les cher de la peau de sous pour essayer
de faire
repousser les nerfs qui était très
atteints on passe trois heures par jour
pendant plusieurs semaines voire mois
essayait de faire repousser ses nerfs et
à la fin on arrive à quelque chose mais
doit commencer à bouger
et puis la main et puis mon bras c'est
là où je découvre que le corps humain
est une machine extraordinaire et qu'il
faut en prendre soin bien sûr mes rêves
repartent
je peux repartir en solitaire et grâce à
des personnes fabuleuses claudine bruno
à la marque qui me redonne confiance en
moi je je repars en mer avant j'étais
intrépide il faut que je le suis
toujours un peu mais il y apprend la
patience
celle qui permet de rebondir dans
quelques jours je vais partir faire une
course mythique qui s'appelle la route
du rhum je vais partir en solitaire sur
ce bateau qui fait 40 pieds environ et
qui va me permettre de je l'espère de
faire un résultat assez incroyable la
course à part de saint malo et ça va
jusqu'à pointe-à-pitre
c'est une course de 3500 milles environ
et nous serons dans ma catégorie 56
participants
voilà le bateau il est bonne en moi je
trouve plutôt pas mal
je vais passer beaucoup de temps en fait
à l'intérieur de cet habitacle ça c'est
moi et voilà c'est un environnement qui
est assez spartiate et inconfortable
mais bon j'aurais quand même ce petit
pont rose qui me permettra de me reposer
c'est un endroit weeki assez spartiate
inconfortable mais en fait on
personnifie vaches pour le bateau je
vais me retrouver à lui parler à me
confiait lui a caressé pour lui demander
d'avancer plus vite on devient un petit
peu zinzin mais on continue à le faire
en mer on doit être connectée à notre
instinct de survie car à l'univers était
assez hostile c'est un ceinture vie
qu'on a tous en nous par exemple l'autre
jour j'étais au large de l'irlande et je
pars pour une grande sieste de 20
minutes au bout de quinze minutes je me
réveille et en sursaut je sors du bateau
et j'ai juste pour le temps de pousser
la barre car juste devant moi il ya un
bateau de pêche qui vient de traverser
croisé ma route
en fait cette situation m'est arrivé
plusieurs fois déjà en mer tous nos sens
sont en alerte et même de notre sommeil
on est attentif à ce qui se passe c'est
assez incroyable
c'est quelque chose qui me surprend
encore toujours d'arriver à voir cet
instinct kir qui ressort quand on quand
on navigue dans tout ce que je fais je
ne cherche pas forcément le bonheur mais
je cherche à relever les grands défis
et puis à vivre intensément ma vie je
vous propose de re fermer les yeux tous
ensemble et d'essayer de rêver de ses
grandes étendues d'eau fragiles que sont
les sondés citent les océans et qui sait
peut-être nous croiserons nous
des rires des cris des rires des rires
mon amoureux dérive le court en me
ramène sur ce caillou que l'on aime
des rires des riffs déry
[Musique]
déry mon amoureux des rires merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]